لليوم الثالث عشر مشاهدينا تتواصل
العمليات العسكريه في السودان في عده
مناطق من العاصمه الخرطوم التي شهدت
اشتباكات بين كل من الجيش والدعم السريع
واسفرت عن دمار هائل كما نشاهد بهذه الصور
بخارطه المعارك في هذا المثلث الذي يشكل
ما يعرف بمثلث الخرطوم الكبرى في العاصمه
نتحدث هنا عن معارك دائره في منطقتين
نتحدث عن منطقه بحري وام دربان حيث نفذ
الجيش السوداني طلعات جويه وغارات على
مواقع للدعم السريع في كل من بحري
واندرمان مقاتلات الجيش استهدفت قوات
الدعم السريع هنا وتحديدا ايضا داخل
الخرطوم داخل العاصمه ولكن في محيط
القياده العامه والتي تعتبر نقطه
استراتيجيه يحاول الطرفان السيطره عليها
ايضا بمحيط القصر الجمهوري حيث تدور
اشتباكات بين الطرفين طبعا هنا
الدعم السريع رد بالمضادات
المضادات الارضيه على هذه الطلعات الجويه
وعلى هذا القصف من قبل الجيش السوداني
الان الى مطار الخرطوم حيث ايضا نفذ الجيش
ومشط مشطت قواته
محيط المطار كما نشاهد هنا بمحيط هذه
النقطه مطار الخرطوم الذي من اول هذه
الاشتباكات هناك اشتباكات دائره بين
الطرفين بمحيط المطار وهناك طبعا بيانات
مضاده بين الطرفين ننتقل الى نقطه اخرى
وهي نقطه الخرطوم بحري اي شمال الخرطوم
وفي ضاحيه كفوري كما نشاهد هنا حيث جددت
المقاتلات الحربيه القصف لاهداف الدعم
السريع في هذه المنطقه منطقه كفوري الذي
يقول بانه الدعم السريع طبعا احبط هجوما
على معسكره بهذه النقطه تحديدا حيث هناك
قوات للدعم السريع وكبد الجيش السوداني
خسائر هائله بهذه النقطه على حد قول الدعم
السريع طبعا ننتقل الى نقطه اخرى والى
منطقه اخرى حيث بي ام درمان اغارت مقاتلات
للجيش على منطقه صالحه هذه المنطقه ومناطق
اخرى ايضا كان هناك غارات عليها هي مناطق
قريبه من سوق ليبيا حيث تتمركز قوات كثيفه
وكثيره
للدعم السريع ويسعى طبعا الجيش السوداني
الى القضاء على هذه القوات اذا كانت هذه
خارطه الاشتباكات داخل الخرطوم حيث تنحصر
الاشتباكات كما شاهدنا بمحيط القياده الع
امه مطار الخرطوم وايضا مناطق اخرى كصالحه
اندرمان وبحري وغيرها
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات